it still should be alive we have made
numerous changes
already signing brianna's law and the
reforms included in our landmark
settlement
with brianna's family and when the top
to bottom review of lmpd
and the sentinel event review of this
case is complete
i'm sure that we'll make more changes
because we must do everything we can
to make sure tragedies like this never
happen
again and police reform is just one
aspect
of the work that we need to do because
justice for briana taylor must be about
more than the decision
that was announced earlier today by the
attorney general
justice for brianna also means a
commitment to eliminating systemic
and structural racism in our city in our
country
to closing the unconscionable wealth gap
in education
health and opportunity that race so
often represents
and i can tell you just as i have been
working on this you have my solemn oath
that i am committed to continuing this
work
and this work really requires all of us
together
to work together to create a future that
doesn't repeat the mistakes of the past
that's the challenge and it's also the
opportunity
that we're facing in this rare historic
moment
in this moment a moment of pain and
anger for me
i have a message to the good people of
louisville
let's turn to each other not on
each other in this moment of opportunity
use your passion your energy and your
commitment
to shape the city that we all want a
city of peace
a city of justice a city of opportunity
in a city of equity that is a city
that all louisvillians deserve with that
chief schroeder and i are happy to take
any questions
again i'd like to remind reporters to
please put your questions in the chat
area and please identify uh the media
that you're with
thank you first question mayor is from
steve bittenbender from center square
he asked if you will call on the
attorney general to release the grand
jury report
do you believe the public needs access
to that information now
yeah i believe that any information that
does not jeopardize
either the attorney general's case or
the fbi case
should now be open for the public to see
to be informed
about all the facts in the case again
that don't jeopardize or imperil any
criminal investigations
so we call on everybody that has that
information to to release
it um
amina allahi from wfpl asks
protesters have demanded that sergeant
jonathan mattingly and detective miles
cosgrove
also be fired mayor fischer will you
fire them
well if at the end of the investigation
if there's a fireball offense
certainly that would be the right thing
to do
now there is a procedure that's outlined
in state law
with the police officers bill of rights
and the fop con
contract it defines what that whole
process looks like so if at the end of
that process that's the case
that's the action to take that action
would be taken
the next question is from nick vogel
burrows from the new york times
and i think this is for chief schroeder
have officers arrested mr hankinson did
he turn himself in
roughly how many people have been
arrested so far in the protest
and what are most people being arrested
for
so as far as detective hankinson he's
not been arrested by members of the
louisville metro police department
as the investigating agency
the attorney general's office would be
the one to coordinate that i do not have
that information
as far as um beyond the protest the
situation is still ongoing
several protesters have been arrested in
the area of bardstown and midland
that situation is currently ongoing as
well i don't have those numbers
nor do i currently have the charges that
they've been arrested for but we can get
that information later
okay the next question is for the mayor
from
christy shank of wave three she asked if
the officers were
found were not found responsible for
brianna's death why would the city
settle
for 12 million dollars it's important
for us to begin the healing process
uh for the city uh for all the community
that we have here in the country as well
so
i believe it was the right decision to
make at the right time and of course
remember there was also police reforms
that were part of that settlement so
that we could have more transparency
more accountability with our police
department it's important that we have
community legitimacy uh with trust with
the police department so that was also
part
of that whole
we have process question from amina
allahi of wfpl
do you agree mayor fisher do you agree
with the attorney general's findings
well i i mean i support the grand jury
process
obviously i've not been privy to look at
all of the information that was part of
the process but i respect the process
and
where it's taking us right now so as the
information that was considered
comes out in the future we'll have the
opportunity to weigh on on whether or
not
i agree with what the resolution of the
case was
or chief schroeder chief
what has been the response inside the
department
to sergeant mattingly's letter sent to
officers
so sergeant mattingly's email we are
aware of the email and we're currently
looking at the situation
it was an email sent that represents his
views not the views of the department
uh each officer would have their own
individual response and
and i can't speak for the majority of
officers on how they feel
about that email
one more question from amina from wfpl
some are concerned militia type groups
may not be treated the same as other
protesters by police would you describe
how lmpd will approach policing the
various groups
we approach policing the various groups
the same we don't judge groups by their
political beliefs
by what side of the political spectrum
they're on
how we judge it is exclusively on the
behavior they demonstrate we
we judge and act upon the behavior we
observe
not from whatever political stance a
group may take
thank you there are no other questions
this afternoon obviously a big day for
our city
and the nation i just want to remind
everybody our country has been here
before
some 50-plus years ago uh there's been
protests before there have been cries
for racial justice
before because racism has haunted our
nation since its founding days
unless all of us commit to ending racism
we will be here again but our history is
not our destiny
while we have much work to do this is
also a time i believe of great hope
for our city and our country i'm
convinced that this movement that's
shaking our city and our country will
lead to a better tomorrow
and that's the work ahead of us let's
seize this opportunity i understand it's
not easy for everybody to do this
but when we're able to look back on this
day and on this time in our history
we need to be able to say we responded
to this call for more equity
to finally work on ending structural
systemic racism
in our country it's our opportunity to
seize that now
we have our full commitment here in the
city of louisville to do that thank you
you